you guys familiar with the hot crazy
matrix
is this something that anybody's
familiar with
please tell me kai that we're able to
play this video a guy went on a date
with yeah who goes to me posted this
graphic are we allowed to play this guy
we are
so listen there's something called the
hot crazy matrix and this is so funny
we're going to back into that we're
going to use this as a template as a
case example this isn't it it's it's a
dude on a blackboard
um it's like date um yeah unicorn you're
going to have to put it into youtube
while we're pulling that up basically
this this professor looking dude
um
goes on and gives a speech about how all
women are some type of crazy and hot
and hot and there's a matrix with this
so the hot crazy what are we allowed to
play here
the guns we'll start we'll start the
video
okay so fast forward to about
four minutes in
this is a real profession yes at any
moment in time any woman that you have
previously located on this chart can
vanish from that location and appear
anywhere else on the chart so what you
have to do is over time
collect some data and once you have a
cluster of data points you can begin to
consider that reliable
now
moving on
you have
this zone here this is below the crazy
line
above an eight hot but still
you know about a seven crazy
this is your date zone
no this is valuetainment this is what's
going on here stay in the date zone
indefinitely these are women that you
introduce to your friends and your
family um they're they're good looking
and they're reasonably not crazy most of
the time is he the man that collected
this right he's the researcher here
we're gonna listen for about 20 more
seconds and we'll get to the point
can we play it in a 2x meter and between
about a seven and a five crazy
this is your wife's own
okay when you meet this girl you should
consider a long-term relationship uh
this zone is not scale to size this this
is a this is a representation and not an
actual if this is not a pie chart
showing you how many of these people are
out there this is simply a
representation of what you're after you
want to be five to seven crazy above and
eight hot that's your wife's own okay
now
below five crazy
and above and eight hot this is your
unicorn zone these things don't exist
thank you
boom and they say if you find this
unicorn you capture her and you do
research on this unicorn that's
basically where it is so essentially
there's a formula to women this is
allegedly you're gonna i'd love to get
your women's feedback on this and
essentially can we just back up so we
don't see him uh covering the screen
no no i'm saying uh like so you see the
matrix
on the left side of the screen is the
crazy
and it basically just so i can see the
screen kai
yeah so on the bottom zero through ten
we're all familiar with how men tend to
judge women zero through ten you know
ten being the hottest out there one
being like dude don't go
anywhere under a five in hotness is just
don't even well that's
correct for all that and then he
basically can as a possibility he starts
the crazy at i believe a four
okay there it is he starts the crazy out
of four meaning like there's no women
who are just like a little crazy there's
medium crazy a lot crazy or the craziest
and then there's hot and then he breaks
this all down i'm gonna circle back to
this
amber heard
beautiful girl can we pull up an image
of her based on what you've seen
from her and her actions
where is she on the hot crazy matrix
we gotta talk about where she belongs
well that's gonna initiate the hot crazy
conversation i want to say one thing yes
go ahead this is driving me insane yeah
okay
yeah then this guy you don't want
someone that's not crazy like being
crazy is is
it's a misconception about what it means
to be crazy being crazy means that you
are relatable
that you can experience that you've
experienced life
if there's a difference between
manageable crazy and unmanageable crazy
maybe yeah amber hurt is crazy but maybe
she can get her [ __ ] together okay
she maybe in a few years she's gonna be
the dream woman you don't you don't know
i don't like this idea that you want
someone who's not crazy yes
i'm crazy
but i don't like this idea that you
don't wanna crazy because crazy is not
always a bad thing why is crazy a good
thing sometimes because it means that
you're a real person and you've
experienced life and and and you get it
so
men are [ __ ] crazy so you're gonna
want you're gonna want someone that gets
you
got it all right
so
have you been
are you the crazy person in the
relationship or is the guy the crazy
person or are your relationships like
let's get [ __ ] crazy together
um
it varies however i remain
to be expressive
what does that mean crazy
so here we go ladies and gentlemen we
have a very beautiful talented woman
who's willing to admit that she's
full-on crazy but she's embracing the
crazy she's not running from it the
thing that it's just
i don't think the perfect woman is just
a [ __ ] robot and that's what this guy
is implying and i don't like that oh i
believe he implied that it was a unicorn
not a robot a unicorn but it's like
she's a 10 and she's like
like just like a
you know
so all women are a little bit of crazy
in the the cre okay crazy
listen natalie yes amber is not shaking
her head here i've i've known amber for
probably six months maybe a little bit
longer she hasn't been that crazy i
don't know she's about to reveal
something what are your thoughts on this
um yeah i think again what is crazy
i am somebody who's fun-loving i travel
solo i enjoy life um i do believe i have
like a healthy perspective and i don't
i'm not super i don't think i'm
manipulative that's why i don't have any
crazy exes and all my relationships are
pretty healthy um i don't think all
women have to be
crazy to the point of hurting people i
think there's crazy and there's a crazy
that hurts
hurts yourself or hurts others yeah like
what is
mentally unstable
and again there are people maybe i'm
i've been a pretty normal
healthy person but if there's a guy who
comes along that stimulates something in
me that makes me a certain way then
where do i appear on the scale like
that's the whole situation here this was
a bad combination of people
and then i'd like to also get into the
man who has created the chart who is
below a six who is crazy himself to be
making such a disgusting ass
[ __ ] video okay who i'd say is
a 10 out of 10 crazy and a zero out of
10 hot but it's the confidence and
that's what men have always no matter
where they are on the scale of
attractiveness they have the this guy is
not doing this ironically he is
confidently putting this out there to
the world he didn't think hmm i wonder
how people are going to take this about
me no he had no [ __ ] issue with him
we're going to come back to this chart
because there's a cliffhanger that i've
left off but we'll get there
manny what's your sentiment on the amber
herd the hot crazy matrix and what these
lovely ladies
you got the yin and yang of female
craziness here the good and the bad they
both embraced their position i agree i
think that uh this is
this is uh very subjective i think what
you find hot and what you find crazy is
on the eye of the beholder some people
want crazy
and some people don't want crazy you and
i are valuing our time we don't want we
don't like crazy in our life right
at least i don't think so not for long
term oh right of course short term
you're not going to invest in crazy well
that's essentially what he says that you
can have a fun zone right but this isn't
who you're marrying yeah i'm at the age
where i i just don't have tolerance for
crazy or some sort of weird
communication in the dating life and
that at the same time i'm also humble
enough to see that i might be the
problem because i might be robotic
in my approach in dating but i've seen a
lot of crazy behaviors and i can see the
red flags from a mile away yeah i just
saved myself so much time just reading
them
good for you so that's my take on this
and i think he did do it ironically i
think he's go to the last like two
minutes i'll tell you when to start it
but just to see that yeah yeah there is
a very famous saying and it is that
crazy women are good in bed
yes so i just want you guys to sit with
that before you reject all crazy women
because
we're [ __ ] awesome
good for you
thank you
way to go
here's what i said relationships in
general i think just drive people crazy
so i like i'll give you a case example
one of my longest relationships a girl
who i happened to marry for a few years
she was very normal we met
nightlife partying live if you've ever
been to south beach we met in the club
it was a very
you know alcohol infused fun-loving
relationship but she wasn't crazy it was
fun it was full-on fun
but over time when you start living with
somebody you can tend to drive each
other crazy and i remember one time
we got in a crazy fight i couldn't even
tell you what it's about and she's like
i'm that sad when i [ __ ] kill myself
i was like whoa whoa and she started
taking pills like
like
a handful of pills
um
to show me how crazy and how crazy i
like i'm so in love with you i'm gonna
count like i was like you are acting
crazy
she didn't die she's good we're actually
friends now we're good and we can joke
about it now but in the moment
in the moment this girl was so in the
moment crazy she was willing to [ __ ]
kill herself
with pills because in that moment it was
the most consuming
crazy
thing going on in her life now you know
peeling the onion walking it back we can
be like hey babe remember that oh my god
i was not set it up but in the moment
things can be very crazy
it's so ironic with the johnny depp
amber heard thing they're very calm and
collective and he's like yes i do
remember she did you know we got some
fights but it in that's looking back in
hindsight years later
but in the moment in the household in
the bathroom but they were [ __ ]
screaming yelling thrown like that's
what relationships do to people so i
don't think it's like women are crazy
and guys are sane or guys are nuts it's
two people coexisting in a relationship
that [ __ ] can drive you crazy
[Music]